let me just bring you an update on this
just in the last few
moments uh we've had a tweet from uh the
white house press secretary kelly
mcinanny with
a letter that she's attached to her
tweet which is from the physician to the
president sean
connelly and this is the memorandum that
he sent to her and it's a health update
on president trump and in that
memorandum he says i released the
following information with the
permission
of president donald j trump following
pcr confirmation of the president's
diagnosis
as a precautionary measure he received a
single 8 gram dose of
regeneron polyclonal antibody cocktail
he completed the infusion without
incident in addition to the polyclonal
antibody
antibodies the president has been taking
zinc
vitamin d family to dean
apologies if i'm pronouncing this wrong
melatonin and a daily aspirin
and as of this afternoon the memorandum
goes on he says the president remains
fatigued but in good spirits he's being
evaluated by a team of experts
and together we'll be making
recommendations to the president and
first lady in regards to
next best steps and it goes on to say
first lady melania trump remains well
with only a mild cough and headache
and the remainder of the first family
are well and tested negative
for sars kovid 19 today so that's an
update from the physician
to the president sean connelly giving
some details of
some of the drugs that have been given
to the
president including an antibody cocktail
is how he describes it there as well as
various vitamins zinc vitamin d
melatonin and aspirin
and also saying that the president
remains fatigued
but in good spirits while melania trump
the first lady
remains well he says with only a mild
cough and headache
so that's the latest from president
trump's physician
released in a memorandum by kaylee
mcconany
assistant to the president and white
house press secretary just in the last
few minutes